cyanide and they little baby teeth I
didn't like the term baby teeth I know
you don't want to talk about what's next
for you guys okay we're not gonna talk
about what's next
okay but can you give us a glimpse into
maybe what you want to do next or is
that out of the question
um well you know the truth is I don't
really know I don't really know I've got
I've got a lot of projects that I've
been working on that I'm very excited
about the question right now is what
comes first
and so I just I have to put a little
more thought to say okay this is like
strategically inspirationally this one
is just ready you know I I was I wrote
was writing all these ideas at the same
this right after MADtv I went through a
depression right okay I that that's the
moment I'm just can we just
that's the moment where I don't know
exactly what you went through
because I remember you had a chance at
the last year of MADtv yeah to get onto
SNL so no they offered it to you because
they wanted you to play Barack that's
right correct doesn't a 2008 and David
this is the writer strike was yeah so
the the guy that owned MADtv mm-hmm
David's awesome yeah I mean it's yeah
it's all googly-eyed gave us all but
right okay said no he was contracted
with us for like a year right or like
even less than that yes you could have
let you go like [ __ ] the year SNL go do
it yeah there's four pointing to it four
more episodes left on your contract on
the contract is like you know they're
gonna laugh you know the network's gonna
laugh and laugh me out of the room if I
even try to bring that up so he would
you know here's the thing now I look
back at it and I don't blame the guy I
mean look I got a got a show you put it
on it's it's it's opposite SNL and this
[ __ ] guy wants to leave the show and
go SNL [ __ ] four episodes laughs
right well it wasn't it wasn't you know
it wasn't a the quit I think he was he
felt insulted and he felt like I didn't
and I I can appreciate how he felt that
you know I I had a contract he gave me
an amazing
opportunity to be on television yeah a
good thing so but I didn't feel that way
at the time I was like this is this is
not right you know this guy's keeping me
from my home he's giving me for my
mother my grandmother my friends in New
York yeah so it was I so I went through
a dark period where you know I was I
didn't know what to do but what my my
brain ended up doing was thinking of it
like a [ __ ] villain from a superhero
so like a narc just what do you do you
outsmart them though they all these
[ __ ] that [ __ ] me are gonna wish
they hadn't in the end
see that's the see something right now
we all have that yeah I call it the hate
box
I hate box I was in the hey I have a
chest in my heart and I can tell you the
names on your [ __ ] right I'm not going
to know I had a lot of names in there
dude right yeah yeah no he's not number
one always but he's in there he's right
there's a couple of other producers in
your boxes in my box it works so what
you do is you put the name or the
situation in that box and you close it
right but what happens is those names in
your heart they grow in the chest right
and you haven't opened it and when you
open it it's now a full-blown creature
mm-hmm okay so you had a [ __ ] box off
a box yeah I mean I was i I was like I
was in this zone of like turning it into
glee I was like oh yeah I was into it
and I start I started writing my goal
was to become a great writer just I was
like okay well if I can't be in sketch
anymore so I can't be in this show cuz I
can't I can't stand to be in it anywhere
I can't be in the the other one so I you
know so what do I do so I was like well
the dream is really is becoming a [ __ ]
or a director
you know there's there's there's all
kinds of you know I'm I got monkey paw
productions it's really that's you
that's me and so it's it's it's horror
it's it's it's sci-fi it's dark it's
comedy it's all of this and ice and I I
really landed on this this mission that
is so satisfying to me of like all of us
underrepresented people and what if what
if the [ __ ] that we have always been
told we can't be in what if we get and
start doing [ __ ] that's better than the
others so that's what I want to do so
I'm I will I will probably never have a
white protagonist in a movie I love
white people my wife's white yeah I
don't I don't
there's enough of those so in many ways
in many ways that was a good thing
absolutely best thing that's happened to
my life Bobby yeah besides meeting Joe
yeah if you're listening right now and
you're going through some [ __ ] you
were raped or whatever it might be I was
just I was on MADtv that was my thing
whatever all right that's whatever it
might be getting paid money making
making me look like I'm complaining
going through your live you you lost
your job at Best Buy okay
right and you can't make ends meet Yeah
right and then like your frog and it
dies and then you get alright whatever
you're going through you know let me see
that you can spin it into a [ __ ]
positive and that's the [ __ ] the
lesson that we learned today mm-hmm
that's the lesson we learned do that
that's amazing so don't and then when
Keegan left cuz yeah yeah
so Keegan was on Mad for two more years
I think
or here I think more you only one way
one more year right that's right Keegan
was on one more year and then you guys
did key and Peele
I'm gonna tell you something right now I
when I saw you guys on the cover
I've Entertainment Weekly mm-hmm
I literally teared up I couldn't believe
it I think we bought that yeah we did
yeah yeah yeah I here's a world up in my
eyes because because you imagine it's
like you know you're in an internment
camp yeah
with somebody and they get out right
like you and our Japanese dudes and
women cameras right people are just
getting shot right right and I'm still
in there how do you really know you were
still in the term a class yeah I'm in
the fence yeah oh dude you don't even
know what the [ __ ] I do but here's the
thing I know you got the first of all
[ __ ] factory in you're in love with a
beautiful soul mate you got a soul mate
that's huge
yeah that's already out of the internal
yeah no you got this you got a [ __ ]
yeah no production you got still the
camp but maybe I'm moved on to the like
the house part of the camp
well you know and then you know we in
all seriousness I I want to sit down I
want to [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] star I
want to develop some [ __ ] we wanted this
I want to figure out what it is because
dude you're using something to you
here's what I'm gonna do man because
coal island I have an idea but I did a
pilot for ABC so if that gets picked up
tonight you know I mean that's not gonna
you know mean part well she's probably
not gonna get picked up we need to go
we're by house want to get out of here I
wanted to get picked up but if it
doesn't picked up yeah I'm gonna pitch
something this year I'd love you mean
and we'll put a monkey can you get out
of that pilot no you see the network
come on you know how you know how it
happened huh
it fell on his lap they just have an
audition they just gave it to me of
course
so I just say yeah oh I want to say this
too before you before we end and I might
get emotional don't look at me don't
look at me pretty if you [ __ ] me up I
want to see this just get in it open
that up yeah I want to see this so a
year ago
you know things aren't going well I need
you to lock eyes yeah that's cool that's
cool yeah that's cool yeah yeah I get a
call from my agent saying that all you
got a commercial right I say watch I
never went out for no [ __ ]
commercial no you got it and I don't got
to tell you what it is but you know
there was a lot of money it was more
money than I've ever done in a year of
work did you know that did you know that
it's anyway so I don't know what it was
so I showed up to the shoot it's 300
more and that's he key and peele there
you know and then I realized that it was
for your Amy it was a commercial
revolved around you and Chelsea's
wedding right then I realized that you
did it yeah that you got me the
commercial no no when's the last time I
cried I really want to cry I can't cry
right now Bob well I'm gonna try it's
all right I just say this and there's an
old Korean tradition yeah I don't know
if you know this that when you do a fav
that big for somebody yeah the Korean
now has to kill somebody for you like
Aria and the guy so it's like just give
me the list whoever it is they'll be
gone Wow do I'm telling right now dude
that gesture was like because people
that I'm missing people
help each other in this business they
don't you know I've I've I I feel like
I've gone out of my way to help people
you know not you know just comics or
whatever right I bring a lot of kids on
the road
I give them more money than they
normally get yeah you know I fly them
out you know I believe it and you know
well that gesture was like like almost
all inspiring for me because it's like
it at the time I was really emotional
about in a good place at all I know that
wasn't a weird place dude I was like it
came at a perfect moment moment where it
it reminded him of two things that he
could still work and that he had a
friend and he had an aisle ally and he
came home he talked about yeah yeah I
would think we talked about it on here
we did but I mean look that was when
when I was when I was a kid a MADtv I
get in there and you were you know you
had been on for a couple years you had
money from the road yeah the most
generous person that I've met yeah and
you would pick up the bill and you would
kit and it wasn't like you picked up the
bill and be like you get it next time
it was like every single time you pick
up the bill yeah you weren't [ __ ]
jack loaded right yeah yeah yeah but
that's that's being Korean too and it
really is cultural because in the
culture like when you are doing better
than somebody else right not that I was
doing better than you but I'd been
around a lot longer I was I think it was
gonna be a little bit more or whatever
and you're also younger you know I mean
I helped Nicole Parker get an apartment
you know things like generosity yeah
that [ __ ] comes back that she comes back
wow you hear that kids
I mean this is like this is a [ __ ] um
this is a dream weaving episode of well
we had time my friend over 50 that's
unbelievable
we're fit perfect 50 minutes Wow
question no no we're not there yet I
just want to say um if you haven't seen
the movie you [ __ ] missed out but
yeah you can still watch it
to watch it and it really is what's up
all right he's a lot to laugh if Gilbert
laughs otherwise
[Music]